i wanted to ask you a question um i'd
love to hear
what you've been learning uh you know
you wrote me a wonderful email and
really laid out a lot of things you've
been thinking about so i'd love for you
to tell the class
um about some of the work
well i got stoned i didn't write the
paper
[Laughter]
then i wrote something but my dog ate it
and uh
yeah no um what
i mean we talked a little bit about it
but one of the things is
you there's a i love to read
so the first thing that i did
and i didn't want it to feel like i'm
doing a good job and doing my assignment
i really wanted it to feel like i want
to do this for me
you know i wanna so um
[Music]
one of the first things i read and that
was a shame that i hadn't read it before
because it's a book that's been around
my
whole life is the autobiography of
malcolm x
and um it is
one of the most harrowing stories
personal stories that you're ever going
to read
uh it's it it's a and
it takes place in roxbury which is right
near where i grew up
and obviously uh malcolm x is growing up
uh in the 1940s
and 50s in roxbury and then moving to
harlem
but that transformation is absolutely
incredible and you can't
read that book and not see that this
person
uh i think his his father dies violently
uh at the hands of racists and his whole
life
is all about the color of his skin and
it completely and he's obviously
incredibly intelligent and incredibly
talented and incredibly good-looking
charismatic
and it's you see how his entire life
is is changed by
institutional racism and
you i completely understand his point of
view by the time you get
to 1960 61 and he's 62 and he's saying
look i'm i respect dr martin luther king
and peaceful protests and everything but
you you understand how we got to
any means necessary you completely
understand it so
there's things as simple as uh
reading uh a book there's also tons of
conversations you can be having
and there are ways that you can think
about how can i take my little world
and make changes in it that will
for me and for the people around me uh
advance advance this movement a little
bit
and so the question is and and it's
we've had a lot of
talks about it with my producer and with
people on the show just talking about
you know what can we do what can we do
in the makeup of our show what can we do
in uh and talking not just with the show
but
my wife and my kids what can we be doing
day in and day out and one of the nice
things is
if my kids are any example one is 16 my
daughter's 16 and my son's 14
they're absolutely um
it's a generation and and their friends
as well
they're very very interested in making
this world
better and rate and racially fairer than
than it has been they're very i mean
it's not the top of their list
and so that's inspiring that's hopeful
now uh i did send your family shirts
that match the one i'm wearing um
did the kids get the black lives matter
uh care package
yes they did and i got your black lives
matter shirt as well
um and uh you know i
and this leads me to my next question
which is
i don't have a confusion about this i
want to make that clear
but there has been a common refrain
uh among certain people in this country
let's say black lives matter well all
lives matter
and i have a point of view about that
very strong point of view about that but
why don't you tell us
what you see the distinction being um
yeah that's that's just not something
that i
debate you know right that's just not a
debate um
and you know i think the way that i i
actually i do touch on that here in this
book i wrote
look you have your own book with you
right there it's a super coincidence um
i didn't even realize it was right here
this is so lucky i'm sorry
uh and actually in this book again which
is an a to z book of radical
moments and movements from american
history many of which we don't learn
about in schools um
b is for black lives matter um it's
about the three women who founded the
movement
um and i actually addressed that so i'm
just going to read
my paragraph about that all right so i
say
some non-black people feel threatened or
left out by the phrase black lives
matter
what about us they've argued why single
out black lives
don't all lives matter the answer is yes
of course every human life matters but
until all humans are actually treated
equally in this country
it is justified and vital to bring
attention to certain
groups who've been routinely
statistically and historically
harmed that is my succinct
uh kind of succinct explanation
what's no it's very good i just was
saying if a sense memory no one's read
to me
uh since i was about five and it was and
it was fantastic and
i missed over you started to nap no no
no no much no they didn't glaze over but
uh much better content than the stuff
they were reading me when i was five
yeah i could we could do this i could i
could zoom with you at night and read
all these stories
what if my wife my wife's gonna walk in
and go who's that woman
that you're talking to me at three
o'clock in the morning
and i'll be like no no we're talking
about race and she'll say yeah okay
i want a divorce well you know it's
i will say one thing i found in writing
these books because the books
that i write with my collaborator miriam
kleinstall
um they're aimed at young readers um but
i do a lot of school visits well in in
the before times i would go into
classrooms a lot
um and i always love to read to young
people but i love reading to high school
students and college students and i'll
read to adults we all really like to be
read too so um
so yeah that's that's that's my answer
um
i i had the same feeling which is uh i
mean immediately which is
the reason uh the state the statement
black lives matter comes
out of this
uh incredibly undeniable this incredible
undeniable history of neglect
that's why the statement needs to be
made in the first
so so then to say look wait a minute no
all lives matter is to deny that we have
an
issue we have a specific racial issue in
this country
yeah and at this point also you know at
this point
in the conversation in the movement in
our country
at this point just say all lives matter
that is an expressly
violent and racist statement at this
point and we're beyond context
in fact here where i live i live in
alameda california right next to oakland
um several black families in town
recently woke up to find their cars
vandalized their tires had been slashed
they'd been keyed
and all lives matter and alm had been
spray painted all over the cars this is
in the
liberal bay area so that's it's it we're
beyond the conversation of
of debating whether black weather the
phrases
you know black lives matter and again i
talk about it in the book it
that phrase began with conversations
amongst
three black women who were friends who
were feeling
unbelievable rage and sorrow
when george zimmerman was acquitted of
the murder of trayvon martin
and they literally just typed on
facebook i feel like black lives don't
matter
and then they turned that in and said
you know what black lives do matter
black lives matter and they started that
as a hashtag
initially to to share love and to uplift
their community
uh and then as it caught on they were
like wow this maybe is a movement and
then they've built it into a global
movement and
um those women are alicia garza opal
tometti and patrice colors and they have
been
propelling this um you know and it's uh
it's
it's an important phrase we put it on
the cover of the book too
um and uh and i do one of the things
when i first started doing these
instagram lives after i
received my promotion to um being in
charge of your whiteness uh
trust me it's a demotion well i have i
wasn't working a lot because of
quarantine so i
i was i had some time take the jobs that
come your way
so but one of the first things i talked
to people about was you know if you're
wondering what to do right now as you're
grappling with what can i do what do i
read which book
get a piece of paper write black lives
matter on it and tape it up in your
window
you know and if you can't take that step
if you're a white person and you're not
ready to do that to make your support
visible
then there's a lot more kind of deep
work that you have to do and and that
could maybe show you what you need to do
but if you could do that
it actually it does have an impact i've
been hearing a lot of really powerful
stories of
of how that that show of solidarity and
support
um has had so much meaning to so many
people